on 38 and still great that was your stat
line for tonight how'd you put your team
in a position to succeed like always to
start this one we got to defend um you
know I think we came out with a
defensive mindset and you know when we
defend we going to give oursel a good
chance to win any ball game you and
Anthony Davis all season have been
trying to emphasize to this team it
doesn't matter what the scores every
single possession matters did you see
that tonight yeah I think so I think
we're we're Contin to get better but the
most important thing we continue to get
healthy um and as we get healthy we get
our length back uh guys are buying
answer and what we want to do
defensively we're helping each other
we're sharing the ball offensively and
we're just playing Laker basketball
right now when it comes to another
championship experience this time on
Saturday what are you most looking
forward to I mean listen it's uh it's
still it's still December so I'm not
getting too crazy about the whole thing
I understand this is this thing has been
great in season tournament but it's
still December you know so uh but it is
another game for us to get better and we
want to we want to try to you know win
the game cuz uh you know we're a team
that wants to get better every single
game we go out there every quarter
possession so we had another opportunity
to do that thanks LeBron good luck onate
doc that's other thing he keeps a
governor sometimes getting too wide eyed
and too high right yeah that was pretty
smart he kind of lowered the
expectations there just a little
bit